we're going to begin this hour with a
look back at a stunning moment in
history involving a very high high
profile allegation of sexual misconduct
now today marks 30 years since law
professor anita hill went before a
senate committee to accuse judge
clarence thomas then a supreme court
nominee of sexual harassment a new
podcast called i like this name because
of anita re-examines her story and what
it means for history and the me too
movement the podcast features the very
first public conversation between anita
hell anita hill is her name and
christine blasey ford who accused
supreme court nominee brett kavanaugh of
sexual assault back in 2018.
here's a look at hill's landmark
testimony in the recent conversation
with christine blasey ford
i thought he respected my work and that
he trusted my judgment anita hill had
only a few days to write her speech but
the impact of her words have been felt
for decades do you swear to tell the
whole truth hill was a 35 year old law
professor from oklahoma she worked for
thomas at the department of education
and the eeoc judge thomas began to use
work situations to discuss sex she said
thomas sexually harassed her multiple
times
thomas denied all allegations it is a
high-tech lynching for uppity blacks i
am here today not because i want to be
26 years later christine blasey ford a
psychology professor accused supreme
court nominee brett kavanaugh of sexual
assault while in high school i was
pushed onto the bed and brett got on top
of me
he too denied the allegations i've never
sexually assaulted anyone both thomas
and kavanaugh were confirmed to the
supreme court
hill and blasey ford talked about their
experiences for the very first time
publicly in a new podcast called because
of anita these consequences of standing
up are real
would i do it again yes
certainly people in my community have
seen
how upended
my life is and what we had to go through
as a family
and all the smear media and the
destroying of reputation and attempt at
destroying career
and
i'm absolutely sure that i would do it
again
and
that's not to say that it hasn't been
really really really hard and that i'm
still
not as okay as i would like to be three
years
out of the situation i certainly wish i
was doing better than i am
hill shared her advice with blasi ford i
just want to say you know to christine
it it does get better it will continue
to get better
but she really needed to hear that too
we'll get better joining us now the
podcast co-host that's salamish tillett
and cindy levy welcome to you both it
was so interesting guys to hear their
two voices together
and i can imagine what it meant to both
of them to be able to talk how did this
come about cindy um i've known professor
hill for years and recently over the
last couple of years got to meet dr ford
and i i knew that there was a
mutual admiration between the two of
them and you know they are sort of this
club of two
you know not a club that either one of
them ever necessarily would have wanted
to belong to but they're the two people
who really understand
what one another has gone through in a
way that the rest of us kind of can't
imagine yeah you point out that both of
them are very private people who didn't
want this attention and now it's turned
out to be one of the most both of them
two of the biggest testimonies public
testimonies that have been life-changing
i'm curious about what stood out to you
because christine said i just wanted to
be a good human being anita said i just
want to be as clear as possible it's not
my job to persuade they both wanted to
they say just do the right thing yeah
you it's one of the things that both
really both salamish and i noticed when
we were talking to them is this sense of
sort of civic duty and patriotism you
know they came forward simply because
they had information and you know with
both of their cases quite reluctantly i
think people forget 30 years to the day
after anita hill's testimony that you
know she very much didn't want to
testify but but was asked by the senate
judiciary committee to do so and the way
they both approached it was simply to
look at it as their job was to deliver
information and they both i think for
their own sanity had to let go of what
the outcome was going to be because it's
been 30 years we've all been listening
to anita hill's testimony
salamisha i cringe i remember watching
it very vividly and the question she was
asked are you a martyr are you a scorned
woman
speak again about the pubic hair on the
cocaine that she had already said two
times i mean i look at that and i go how
was that even allowed to to happen the
way it did yeah what are you thinking
today what does it mean to us today
today why was 16 years old when i was
watching the testimony so i didn't even
understand quite what was happening
either in terms of sexual harassment nor
the language that
she was
alleging clarence thomas used in the
workplace
but today i think one of the things
that's striking is the differences in
the experiences that
professor
hill had versus dr ford in the kind of
etiquette in the hearings
social media of course the attacks on dr
ford were differently
shown compared to professor hill but
also i think the legacy of anita hill
for all of us is to have this language
of sexual harassment and also to
understand that these aren't villains in
someone else's story these these are
three-dimensional women and one of the
things that i think was so compelling
about hearing them in conversation with
each other is that um their humanity
their believability and their their
trustworthiness was clear as day and so
when you think about the attacks that
have continuously still mounted against
them um i think their voices together
provide an alternative the legacy really
is uh illusion shattering as you put it
uh the language of sexual harassment was
not commonplace in 1991 the first survey
of sexual harassment was 1976. yeah talk
about the journey we've been on well and
by the way that was done in red book
magazine it wasn't done by the
government no one in the government was
really trying to to figure this out and
in fact the statistics are so very poor
there isn't a lot of great data about it
but we know that it's very very persua
pervasive and that probably about one in
three women and close to that of men
have experienced it in the workplace do
you think it is continued at a
consistent level or can we say that
because of conversations that began with
anita hill it's declined either one of
you take that yeah i mean i think
because of anita hill we
saw that there were shifts in
legislation and workplace protections
but the problem is that 30 years that
was kind of an immediate aftermath of
her testimony 30 years later we haven't
seen significant protections or new um
uh you know in terms of harassment in
terms of how much people can sue for
those things haven't changed so there
was an immediate bump so to speak and 30
years later we're still dealing with a
lack of enthusiasm and a lack of
critical will to deal with these issues
i remember during the anita hill case
men were relatively silent yeah do you
believe now in 2021 that we are using
our voice more when women come out yeah
i mean i would say one thing that that
is important to note is that um the
racial dynamics of the case too and the
ways in which there was a real divide
amongst african-american men and women
in response to anita hill's testimony
but uh at the time and we talked about
this in our second episode a group of
black women took out an ad in the new
york times african-american women in
defense of ourselves also in defense of
anita hill a speed up to christine
blasey ford
a group of men an interracial group of
men intergenerational group of men took
out a similar ad in new york times in
support of dr ford so i would say that's
lots of progress um and anita hill talks
about that in our that episode as
something that what a what a way to
think about a black woman's legacy that
these men are have been so moved by her
voice or black woman's voice and now
they're coalescing around these issues
on race and on gender and it also talks
about how it's not the work of one
generation to solve all these problems
it's going to be multi-generational yeah
the conversation continues it does yeah
uh the podcast is because of anita uh
salamisha tillett uh cindy levy thank
you very much thank you